Moscow is blaming key for
a strike on a strategic bridge
known as the gate to Crimea.
A Russian installed
official
said the damage is forcing traffic
to be temporarily rerouted
The Chun Ha Bridge connects Occupy Crimea
and Russian held parts of Ukraine's
southern her southern region.
So far, no official comment from Kiev.
Which has said
it wants to retake
all of its occupied land.
Moscow annexed Crimea
from Ukraine back in 2014.
CNN's Ben Wedeman joins us
live in separate city Ukraine.
What have you learned about this, Ben?
Well, what we understand,
according to the
head of the Russian occupied zone region,
that four missiles were fired
at this bridge
early Thursday morning
and that one actually struck it,
causing a large crater.
And as you said,
all traffic is now being diverted
from this bridge on the eastern side
of the line of the area
that connects Crimea with Harrison.
Now, according to this official,
they believe that what could have struck
the bridge
is one of these storm shadow missiles,
a long range
cruise missile
that has about
range of more than 250 kilometers.
This is a missile
jointly developed by France and the U.K.
And it was just last month
that Britain announced
that it would be supplying the Ukraine
with that missile.
Now, as far as we can tell,
the Ukrainians are being a bit
mum about all of this.
CNN did contact
someone with the intelligence service
who said that that Ukraine will continue
its security,
its intelligence,
its military
and also local resistance
to try to expel the Russians
and bring Ukrainian control
back to Crimea,
since it was occupied in 2014.
But he said that beyond that,
their only
comment is to be continued Max.
Okay.
Ben Wedeman in south reaching Ukraine.
Thank you.
Ukraine says
its slow, grinding
counter-offensive is showing
noticeable success in the south.
It posted this video
reportedly showing
Ukrainian strikes in the
RIA sector on Wednesday.
Ukraine says it destroyed the equivalent
of three Russian companies
over the last day and its troops
continue to advance
Kiev also says it repelled
multiple Russian attacks
in the Donetsk region on Wednesday.
But Russian President
Vladimir Putin claims
without evidence
that Ukraine
has slowed down its offensive
because it took serious losses.
Ukraine says
Russia is employing new tactics
in its aerial strikes across the country.
It says Russian operators fly
drones and missiles
along rivers
to avoid Ukraine's air defenses.
But as Fred Pleitgen reports,
Ukrainian Navy ships
are trying to counter that move
Night after night, a common theme,
Russian aerial attacks
on Ukraine's cities.
Air defense viciously fighting back
from land, the air and from the water.
We got exclusive access to Ukrainian
Navy patrol boats
that are part of that fight.
The Ukrainian say
the Russians offered to fly drones
and even cruise missiles along rivers
to avoid air defenses.
That's why boats like this
one played important role in both cities.
But also a critical infrastructure,
saying
the commander
who only gave his name
as Anton says
air defense is a key
component of their mission.
Are you effective So I cannot answer that
question of how effective we are,
but so are we affected?
I will say yes.
As Ukraine presses on
with its counter
offensive, Kiev acknowledges
the Russians are putting up
stiff resistance.
Every yard of territory, hard fought.
We would certainly like
to make bigger steps.
The Ukrainian
president says
They are smaller than we want,
but nevertheless, those who fight
shall win.
Moscow
claiming they are repelling Ukraine's
attempted advances.
Russian President
Vladimir Putin saying
his troops are wearing
the Ukrainians down.
Currently, we're seeing a certain lull.
It has to do with the fact
that the enemy
is suffering serious losses.
The Ukrainians fear
the Russians may try to infiltrate
and destabilize cities
like Kiev or smuggle weapons here.
So the Navy crew searches
all boats and barges on the river
in this search.
It was an all clear
there, all megastores and all the
suspected vessels.
In the meantime,
we will be surrounding them
to make sure
that nobody is going
to leave the vessel that they have
will not be under attack.
Their work,
they say, even more pressing
after the recent destruction of the novel
Kafka Dam,
which the Russians
and Ukrainians blame on each other.
Syria is also a strategic object,
especially now, as you can see,
what happened in Moscow.
So now you can understand
how it is important to make it
safe and secure a place.
Fred Pleitgen, CNN, Kiev.